okay so in this presentation we're gonna
go over some of the basic
characteristics of bacteria and now when
we typically think of bacteria we think
of germs and gross and disease and and
really that's that's kind of a missed a
missed stereotype of bacteria most
bacteria fairly harmless of course the
ones that do cause disease you know kind
of scare us for good reason let's go
overhead let's go and look at some of
the basic features
so when we look at the cell structure
probably the most obvious difference of
bacteria versus other organisms on earth
is bacteria are classified as
prokaryotes you've seen the term
prokaryote many times school year so I
hope you're fairly comfortable with it
but a prokaryote again it's a cell
without a nucleus or membrane-bound
organelles when you look at the picture
here you can see very few parts from
earlier in the school year there's no
vacuoles there's no endoplasmic
reticulum or Golgi bodies or
mitochondria or chloroplasts or
lysosomes those are all membrane bound
organelles
there's no nucleus the nucleus is a
membrane-bound organelle so prokaryotes
are very simple in structure very basic
and you can see that there is blue
strands of DNA in the picture and
they're just kind of floating freely in
the cytoplasm while they do have
ribosomes and if you recall from earlier
in the school year ribosomes job is to
create a protein so if they do have
ribosomes that tells me that ribosomes
are not membrane bound if you recall
from earlier in the school year we
mentioned ribosomes are made from our
RNA ribosomal RNA and so watch this
animation here we have a strip of a's
yous c's and g's at the bottom of the
picture
that's messenger RNA and the letters Aug
is the start codon and transfer RNA just
delivered an amino acid well if you
remember from our next chapter the
ribosome just goes down from codon to
codon to codon
so now that the ribosome is moved to the
next codon AGG transfer RNA will bring
the proper amino acid and one by one the
ribosome just goes down one codon at a
time so now the ribosome is that you you
see if you remember that amino acid
chart you could look up you you see I
don't remember what it is off the top of
my head but tRNA brings over an amino
acid and now this growing chain of amino
acids is larger and larger and larger
this again is the process of translation
so the ribosome moves down to the next
codon CAA and transfer RNA brings over
another amino acid and ultimately we
eventually come to the stop codon UAA as
a stop codon if you recall a protein is
simply a chain of amino acids so write a
ribosome job is to build proteins
through the process of translation and
yes bacteria and prokaryotes have them
when we look at this animation we see
how many bacteria are able to swim how
they're able to move they have a
flagella which is a cell part that you
can see in the animation just kind of
twists and corkscrews and and that
provides the whip-like motion for
bacteria to propel themselves through
their liquidy environment if we come
back to this picture right here we see
these yellow hairs that go all around
the cell sometimes students will mistake
them for cilia because we learned cilia
earlier in the school year kind of look
like this and cilia are used for motion
and movement kind of like the flagella
however these are called pili pili is
the plural version pilis is singular
but pill I is the plural version and
these prokaryotes have pill I which acts
as an anchor and you're also going to
see another important role when when we
look at the sex life of bacteria till I
play a role in bacteria
and in their sex lives we'll talk about
that in a few minutes and you saw on the
previous picture and you'll see that
previous picture again but bacteria have
three outer layers one reason why
they're so difficult and you can see the
three our outer layers in this picture
here one reason why they're so difficult
to treat is that they have not one not
two but three outer layers for defense
their outer layer is called a capsule
and you can see in this picture here
it's labeled green now not all bacteria
I don't think all bacteria have capsule
but we'll talk about gram-positive and
gram-negative bacteria and up de but
bacteria have this outer layer called a
capsule and it just adds to their
protection and when we look at this
picture we see something really
interesting we don't see this in
eukaryotic cells but when times are
harsh and endospore can grow and
surround the DNA of the bacteria and
everything on the outside of the
endospore can very well die in this
harsh environment maybe it's too dry or
there's too much radiation from the Sun
but ultimately what's inside the endless
floor has a good chance of surviving so
when the environment becomes more
hospitable the endl spore will just grow
into a new cell and that because the DNA
was protected the bacteria goes about
its life so it's a real neat little
adaptation that some bacteria have this
is called an endoscope
if we just bring the picture back up
again if you want to take a look at some
of the prokaryotic parts that are common
to bacteria this is a really nice
picture you can see the three outer
layers the capsule and gold the cell
wall in green and the cell membrane in
gray and again the main thing to note
when you browse over the pictures no no
membrane bound organelles no
mitochondria no vacuole no nucleus so
this is the basic structure structure of
bacteria cells
so the next thing I want to look at is
some of the basic shapes that we see
with bacteria
well bacteria often grow in colonies so
they often will live in groups that's
what a colony is a group of bacteria
cells and from the picture you can see
that there are three basic shapes three
basic shapes in the picture you have a
science word and then a the common word
of course
if you're in my my class I want you to
know the science word so on the top
right it says bacillus rad shape in my
notes it says bacilli rod-shaped well
the difference in spelling is simply the
singular version bacillus and in the
notes
Vasili is plural so bacilli is plural
vassilis is singular when you look at
the picture on the left in the picture
it says spherical Coxie
but in my notes it says spherical caucus
again that's just the plural versus the
singular cox eye is plural caucus is
singular they both mean spherical in the
bottom right hand corner picture in the
picture it says spur Ella helical or
spiral spur Ella is the plural version
spur Elam
like it says in the notes right there
spur Elam is the singular version of the
word so the words mean rod spherical and
spiral shaped of course I want you to
know the science words
and so when you look at this bacteria
right here this is a bacteria called
lactobacillus acidophilus and when you
look at the spelling of the word
lactobacillus you can figure out okay
you can see in the picture that it's
rod-shaped and again in the name of the
bacteria you can see the word bacillus
which means rod
here's a bacteria called streptococcus
pneumoniae it is the bacteria that gives
us pneumonia and you can see the word
streptococcus in the word streptococcus
you can see the word caucus so these are
spherically shaped bacterial cells
and here's another one here magneto spur
Elam magneto
tackett con I don't know how to
pronounce these some of these words but
you can see again the reason I'm showing
you this as you can see in some of the
names of bacteria you can figure out
what their what their shape is based on
their name magno spare Elam well that's
the genus name and so there I would bet
that all the bacteria in this genus are
spiral-shaped
we look at how bacteria reproduce
well bacteria reproduce to what's called
binary fission it's an asexual
reproduction where one cells simply
splits into two cells you can see this
animation of one bacterial cell dividing
slowly going through various stages and
becoming two cells so we talked about
this earlier in the school year when we
were learning about meiosis and mitosis
well binary fission is very similar to
mitosis in that both cells that are
created have identical sets of DNA
they're clones they're exact duplicates
of one another so the the downside of
reproducing this way is that the
individuals that are created have less
genetic diversity now there's there's an
obvious upside an obvious benefit of
reproducing asexually is that you don't
need another partner so you're able to
reproduce ends and carry on your species
existence without the help of another
partner now one thing I want to mention
is even though it says that the
bacterial cells that created are
identical and that this leads to less
genetic diversity bacteria have actually
figured out a way to add genetic
diversity to themselves bacteria do this
process called conjugation and in the
animation we got a yellow cell on the
left and an orange cell on the right and
the yellow has penetrated the orange
cell and when the yellow cell penetrates
the orange cell you're gonna notice that
the yellow cell will transfer a red sir
Euler object to the cell on the right
that red circular object represents the
plasmid or which is DNA of bacteria so
bacteria can actually be the process
called conjugation where the bacterial
cell on the Left
penetrates the bacterial cell on the
right the T cells connect to one another
by what's called the sex pillows
remember pilis is the singular version
of the word p lie is the plural version
so one of the things we mentioned a few
minutes ago I when we first started
these notes was that the pill I are used
for attachment well one reason that one
way that bacteria used they're polite to
attach is in conjugation after they
connect you can see again the in the
animation the cell on the left has
transferred a red circular object to the
cell on the right that red circular
object is called a plasmid and basically
DNA of the bacteria on the Left
transferred to the bacteria on the right
so this process is how bacteria can
create genetic diversity one thing I do
want to make clear is that conjugation
is not really a form of reproduction
look in the animation at the beginning
of the animation there are two cells at
the end of the animation there are still
two cells so the conjugation is not
really reproduction because they're not
making more of themselves
what conjugation is how bacteria can
exchange their DNA when it comes to
reproduction bacteria reproduced by
what's called binary fission
you
when we look at nutrition
how do bacteria obtain their nutrients
so there's a few patterns that we see we
see that many of them are heterotrophs
we brought up the term earlier in the
school year called saprophyte so that
they feed on dead matter so bacteria and
fungus are saprophytic they feed on dead
matter they decay they cause dead
organisms to decay like dead trees
fallen leaves animals that may have died
well decay and feed on their dead body
these are what we call sacrifice and
bacteria are good examples
well also some bacteria are parasites
here you see somebody's leg and foot
with a very nasty parasitic bacterial
infection and hopefully for this person
they're their bodies their body was able
to respond well to the antibiotics and
and hopefully the person was able to
keep their foot but often there are some
real nasty bacteria out there by the
name of flesh-eating bacteria and like
their name implies they eat flesh
they're parasitic and they eat flesh
sometimes unfortunately body parts have
to be amputated because the bacterial
infection can be so devastating some
bacteria however are autotrophs and
there's a group of autotrophic bacteria
there's a group of bacteria called
cyanobacteria we'll learn about from
another day cyanobacteria perform
photosynthesis and like any kind of
autotroph they use the energy from the
Sun they perform photosynthesis and they
turn the water carbon dioxide and
sunlight into glucose and in the process
of doing that they also create a waste
molecule called oxygen
so one thing I want to mention whether
they're heterotrophic whether they're
autotrophic they're really essential to
healthy ecosystems here we see a diagram
I hope you recognize from earlier in the
school year remind ourselves that
bacteria play a vital role in the
nitrogen cycle if you look in the
picture that there are bacteria all over
this picture that perform what's called
nitrogen fixation where they convert the
nitrogen that's in the air into the
forms that are more usable to life
let's also remember that earlier in the
school year we learned about food webs
well here's a food web right here and at
the very bottom of this food web we can
see bacteria bacteria are important
decomposers in returning nutrients back
into the ecosystem so the there's a
couple things I just wanted you to keep
in mind as we go through and learn about
bacteria not all bacteria are harmful
and cause disease like you saw in that
person's infected foot a few minutes ago
well how do bacteria use oxygen how do
they do respiration well there's three
groups of bacteria we saw or we see
first of all here we have a test tube
filled with like a chicken broth chicken
noodle soup broth and you can see that
there's these little black dots at the
top of the test tube
well those are bacteria and you can see
that they're growing near the top near
the loose-fitting cap because the cap is
loose oxygen from the outside can get
into that test tube and the bacteria use
that oxygen for their cellular needs and
so we call bacteria that have to have
oxygen we call them obligate air robot
aerobic means they they use oxygen and
think of obligate like they're obligated
to use oxygen
well here's another pattern that we see
we also see other bacteria that are just
the opposite they cannot live in oxygen
here in this picture the the black dots
in the picture these are bacteria and
they're at the very bottom of the test
tube they're trying to use their
flagella and swim down to the very
bottom of the test tube away from the
oxygen for these groups of bacteria
oxygen is actually a poison and toxic
and will kill them so they're swimming
purposely to the bottom of that test
tube trying to get away from the
loose-fitting cap where there's oxygen
there at the top so some bacteria cannot
live in oxygen whatsoever
we'll talk more about these bacteria
another day
and then there's the bacteria that can
go either way these are called the
facultative aerobic I also heard them
called facultative anaerobic the picture
says anaerobic my notes in your book say
aerobic I've heard it go both ways as
long as you remember the facultative and
in the picture at the bottom of the test
you we can see there are some bacteria
living near the bottom so some bacteria
are avoiding the oxygen and they're
swimming down to the bottom of the test
tube however most of the bacteria are
growing near the oxygen so even though
Faculty of anaerobic can live with or
without you can see from the picture the
vast majority of the bacteria prefer
oxygen they're more efficient in their
cellular needs
when we look at this picture right here
there's a picture of of the bacteria
called tuberculosis actually there's a
bacteria that causes the disease called
tuberculosis and the bacteria that
causes tuberculosis lives inside of your
loans so tuberculosis is actually fairly
common and it says in the question here
the bacteria that causes TB lives in
your lungs TB is tuberculosis so from
those three definitions right there
because it lives in your lungs which one
do you think it is well I hope you chose
this option right here obligate aerobic
simply because if the bacteria lives in
the person's lungs and you know lungs
take in oxygen they're gonna have to be
able to survive with oxygen so as we
wrap up these notes let's just take a
look take a moment to pause and ask you
okay from this picture what shape is
that yeah it's the spherical shape but
what's the name for it here's the answer
three two one again these are called Cox
Cox is plural caucus is singular here's
another question
name this bacterial shape these are the
rod-shaped bacteria I'm going to show
the answer in three two one
so the rod-shaped bacteria at bacteria
are called bacillus again bacillus is
singular
Vasili is plural
so in this picture here you can see
dozens and dozens and dozens of little
tiny threads going around the outside of
this bacterial cell name these parts I
hope you know these are the parts called
these are the parts called the pill I
Pillai is plural pilis is singular and
bacteria often have hundreds of these
pili in order to attach themselves
and the last one name this process that
has shown in the animation in the
animation the DNA is separating the
cells started to divide right down the
middle and ultimately you got pop two
new daughter cells and so name this
process that's shown in this animation I
hope you know this is called binary
fission binary fission
and now that we've reached the end go
ahead and pause the video and try to
answer these questions right here if
you're in my class bring your answers to
me before or after school one day I'd be
happy to check them for accuracy button
pause the video good luck